hey guys I'm Ryan right so today I'm
checking out Shia LeBouf freestyle rap
part 1 and part 2 I'm very excited to
watch this this guy knows how to take
advantage of the internet and become
more and more famous I've always liked
Shia LaBeouf so here we go him rapping I
wonder if he just stole the rapping is
acting like a freestyle let's see this
semi my god you can't really fly breathe
and thought of sick y'all still grip
like a ride team and shame you pull down
the adjective and I keep out of key you
can see me I'll wrap it shake
[Music]
watch me and I'm free I feel [ __ ] I'm
making it watch me I'm the greatest you
can't stop me and I'm making still
breaking down potatoes like I'm [ __ ]
Galileo and making no sense and that
don't really matter though eat any
rapper like I've eaten tuna casserole
yes no spit a punch
watch me yo watch I give a [ __ ] I still
spit it cuz ya'll so cause doubt coming
from the love doubt yeah la you can wash
me enough bump-out i'll give others
don't walk about something and a sore on
the ground or out kids call me plug me
[Applause]
commodity quality is what is God is here
my philosophy is much farther than what
your eyes can see as cash you could get
the fast cash but I've got a cache mass
so you know I got the last cool all
right watch part you baby key come here
for one second he's gotta watch this one
video with me this is one part too
you got to watch part two with me so
this is Shia LaBeouf freestyle flick
[ __ ] are making watch me I'm the
greatest you can't stop me and I'm
making still breaking down potatoes like
a [ __ ] make no sense in that don't
really matter though eat any rapper like
I'm eatin tuna casserole yes no spit a
punch
watch me yo watch I give a [ __ ] because
Y also cause doubt coming from the love
doubt yeah la wash me enough bump-out
about something and also on the ground
around kids call me Tommy
the quality is what is God is here my
philosophy is much farther than what
you're asking as cash you could get the
fast cash but I got a cast mass so you
know I got the last yeah that's pretty
cool rise apart - I haven't seen part
two yet watching cause he's sick when he
be coming with these bars and [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] it's me I'm so [ __ ] disgusting
Boston already said so and you already
know me homie you can't really close
unless you know me and you told me it
don't make no sense for us no kidding
like a condo rocking like a novice but a
rocket like a rocket is so disgusting
don't get it busting us to upset though
look if my [ __ ] is still ripping give me
words flip it like a Emma dextrous and
I'm still flex your kid you can [ __ ]
with this dog and the best in the
Western shake if you could give me the
shoe you know the shoe [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
though shifting gear spit flow [ __ ] [ __ ]
rip though
no none of that transformers is the
dummy right
all right I love how he just [ __ ]
clowned on transformers now now he's
really cool for doing that I don't know
he's so awesome and I want to know where
he is
would you date him probably really I'm
not jealous that was a cool rap you know
like I I mean the one thing about the
rap that I didn't really like didn't
seem like it really made sense it seemed
like he was really emphasizing rhymes a
lot I don't know some of it sounds a
little familiar I wonder if he stole
some of it nah you think so I mean I
want to be that surprised but still he's
having a fun time with friends hey don't
yawn I know it's 8:00 in the morning but
come on we're on camera baby I mean he
did reference the fact that he's Jewish
he reference transformers so I don't
think it's stolen but that was pretty
cool I'm a little jealous of the guy
were like pretty close in age and he's
just seems significantly more talented
than me you like Shia LaBeouf don't you
you're attracting him that just turned
you on the internet no yeah you're
turned on right now it's 8:00 in the
morning you're turned on by Shia LaBeouf
rapping Shia LaBeouf want her to have a
threesome with us would you do it oh man
come on
anyway for the channel you can subscribe
to the real rejects you can check out
Veronica's channel where every video she
looks exactly like it's 8 in the morning
you can follow us on Facebook Instagram
Twitter and vine and baby help me do a
shout out
Thomas Robles hey Ryan
I've been watching all of your videos on
YouTube for quite a long time can I
please have a shout-out PS love your
dick jokes they always get me dude
my dick jokes are awesome they're really
good for you Thomas Robles baby must've
be a poke in make jokes at this pic
jokes lick jokes and I prick jokes I go
around here for Thomas I gotta be honest
I gotta go around here he's the boss mr.
Robles go homeless do these things and I
give you a toast list I want to give
something to you I want to give a
shout-out how about this shout-out you
do these things you little stout my Cub
Scout Thomas you want a shout-out so I
be shouting I be haul the ring I'd be
freestyling I'd be mopping a new rhyme
all the fun but Thomas I do this I do
this for you I give this a little rap
kiss I do this and I feel so much bliss
when I think of Thomas Robles Saint in
the morning give me a break
it wasn't bad for 8:00 in the morning
really it's [ __ ] early